Hello everybody and welcome back to the
channel. Today we'll be making a video
on how to build something like Dropbox
or Google Drive. Now, for some reason, I
have a lot of people in my life calling
me a Dropbox. Maybe because I take in so
much information and data. Uh I think
it's a euphemism for like I learn
quickly and I learn a lot, but I'm not
100% sure what they mean. Anyways, let's
go ahead and talk about how to build it.
Dropbox is a service that allows you to
create files and share them with other
users. People with access to a file on
Dropbox can expect that as other users
make changes to the file, they are
synced to their computer in the
background. Let's formalize our
requirements. A user can upload or edit
an existing binary file. Other users who
have permissions to that file should
have those changes synced in the
background to their machine. The
previous 30 days of file history should
also be maintained. Our last functional
requirement has to do with write
conflicts. Because file syncs to other
user machines are not required to be
instant. It's possible that two users
can upload conflicting versions of a
file concurrently. In this case, we must
store both versions as separate files
which subsequent users can then manually
coalesce. This is how Dropbox handles
these changes. Dropbox typically limits
the number of users that a file can be
shared with to 500. Beyond that, they
won't sync file changes to users
proactively and will just hand out a
link which users can employ to fetch the
latest version of a file. On a daily
basis, Dropbox sees 1 billion file
uploads and modifications. This means
that there are around 12,000 operations
per second. I have seen that Dropbox
gets something like 200 pabytes of new
data on a daily basis, meaning that the
average file size is something like 200
kilobytes, assuming that all of those
operations are file uploads. When it
comes to a service like Dropbox, we're
dealing with static files. Dropbox does
not enforce a particular file type like
a txt file for example. This means that
any logic that we employ in our service
must work for general large bite arrays.
As we discussed in our pacein video,
this means that we'll want to use an
object store to back our files. These
object stores are infinitely scalable,
fault tolerant, and cheap, and they make
for a very effective place to store
large files that aren't frequently
modified. When a user uploads a file to
Dropbox, they can first put the file
into S3. Then our service must keep
track of the location of this file
corresponding to a Dropbox file ID. We
can do that in our file metadata table.
After a user writes a file to object
storage, they'll add a row to the
metadata table to indicate where it
lives. In the previous slide, I implied
that our metadata table has the schema
file ID and S3 location. In reality,
this isn't the case. Imagine that I
uploaded a 1 GB text file and the next
day I edit a single sentence of it.
Recall that we need to keep the previous
30 days worth of file versions. If I
have to store each version of a file in
its entirety, I'm spending a lot of
extra money to store duplicate data.
Additionally, uploads to S3 itself will
take longer, as will downloads of file
changes, as we'll have to send or
receive an entire gigabyte over the
network. In reality, Dropbox splits all
uploaded files into small chunks,
variably sized in response to the size
of the file itself, though typically a
few kilobytes to a few megabytes. It
runs an algorithm called Raven
fingerprinting to try and create small
chunk diffs so that each user only has
to send chunks that don't already exist
to S3. Each chunk is identified by a
hash or a fingerprint. All in all, we're
going to be pushing out more chunks than
me after my 4 a.m. Taco Bell runs. And
no, it's not always from the same hole.
To map a file to its chunks, we need a
database table. In this case, we can use
the following schema. The file ID, the
version number of the file, the chunk
hashes included in the version. This
also implies that we need a separate
table to match fingerprints to their S3
location. That's what our chunk
locations table is for. It has a simple
schema. File ID, chunk fingerprint,
chunk S3 location. Including the file ID
here means that we can partition this
table on the file ID, therefore allowing
for fast joins with our file chunks
table when getting locations for a
single file version. When a client is
uploading file chunks, they should do so
in the following order. First, they
upload them all to S3. Then they upload
any new locations to the chunk locations
table. Finally, they add all chunk
fingerprints in the new version of the
file to the file chunks table. Doing our
operations in this exact order ensures
that if anything fails, chunks just
become orphaned. There is never a case
where we believe that a chunk exists in
a file, but we don't have its location.
Just like in our past video, we don't
want to have to route our chunks through
our application servers on the way to
S3. We can instead upload them directly
to S3 from our client by using
pre-signed URLs. As a refresher, the
flow here involves the client asking the
application server to create a
pre-signed URL. The server then responds
with it. Finally, the client can issue
an HTTP put request with its chunk in
order to upload the file. If two clients
upload changes to a file at a similar
time, they won't have the opportunity to
incorporate each other's changes.
Dropbox handles this by storing conflict
versions because these can be any types
of files and not just text files. We
can't make any assumptions about how to
resolve concurrent rights on our own
like Google Docs might. Simply put, a
concurrent write here can be defined as
a write that was made from a user that
didn't have the most up-to-date version
of a file when they made it. This is
actually fairly easy to check in our
metadata table. When a client tries to
add a new version of a file, they can
check the version that they edited
against the latest version. In the event
that this was a conflicting, write,
Dropbox actually creates an entirely new
file and name for this version. This
way, the conflicting version can be
branched on and edited accordingly. We
can accomplish this by simply copying
the chunk locations and then the file
chunks from the old file to the new file
ID. We don't have to replicate any S3
data. We also need to ensure that the
same set of users that have permissions
for the first file have permissions for
the newly created one because we're
relying on the database as our
methodology of ordering all rights. Here
it's important that our metadata
database use single leader replication.
This allows us to have one source of
truth leader node. While in theory this
may be achievable with quorum
consistency, not all quorum based
databases provide the type of acid
guarantees that we rely on here. They
also may allow things like sloppy
quorums or hinted handoff to provide
availability over data consistency. In
Dropbox, you have user permissions on a
file that determine whether a user can
view or edit a file. This can be
represented with a file ID, user ID, and
permission level. However, files can
also be part of folders which users can
also have permissions on. Note that
Dropbox does not allow conflicting
permissions. So, a user can't have two
different permission sets between nested
folders. In addition to our table that
lists user permissions per file, we need
to generalize it to be user permissions
per entity where an entity is either a
file or a folder. We can actually have a
separate entity table with a bunch of
ids and also a pointer to a parent
entity. That way to get all user
permissions for a given file, we first
resolve its own permissions. Then we
resolve the permissions of its parent.
Then we resolve the permissions of that
folder's parent all the way until there
are no parents. Admittedly, this could
be pretty slow. In today's deep dive
section, we can discuss how to speed
this process up considerably. The last
important piece of this video before we
get to our highle design is talking
about fan out. You should be starting to
sense a pattern by now when you hear
that certain changes have to be
delivered to many subscribed users. The
same was the case in our newsfeed and
our messenger problem. After we upload
our data to the file chunks table, we've
created a new version of a file that
needs to be delivered to many consumers.
We can employ change data capture on
this table in conjunction with Kafka
consumers in order to deliver the set of
file chunk fingerprints to each
interested user. On the receiving end of
things, we can have a table called
incoming file chunks which contains the
latest version of each file per
interested user and those file chunks
that that version contains. If we model
this with Cassandra, we could have the
receiving user ID be the partition key
and the file ID be the sort key so that
subsequent versions of files overwrite
earlier ones and multiple writes for the
same file are item potent. Clients can
pull this table on an interval, compare
the chunk fingerprints with the ones
they've locally cached and then pull in
the chunks that they're missing from S3.
This is actually a really great place to
use a CDN. In the event that there are
100 interested users in a document,
their computers will all fetch new
chunks of it around the same time. This
way, our content will be effectively
cached after the first read and will
also save money on API requests to S3.
Let's now evaluate our highle design.
Imagine that we've got two clients that
both share access to the same document
and one of them edits it. The other one
must now receive the changes. Upon
editing the document, the editor's
client first performs Raven
fingerprinting to identify the new
chunks that it needs to upload. Then it
requests a series of pre-signed URLs
from an application server, one per
uploaded chunk. After this, our client
will send all of the chunks to S3 in
parallel. From there, it can report
their locations to the chunk locations
table. Finally, the editor will update
the file chunks table to reflect the new
set of fingerprints in the new file
version. At this point, we'll take the
new set of fingerprints for the file
version and pipe them into Kafka via
change data capture. Our Kafka consumer
will recursively resolve the set of
users that are subscribed to changes in
this file by reading the entities table
and the entity permissions table. Note
the sharding of these tables on the top
level folder ID. This allows us to just
query a single shard to get all
permissions for a given folder. We'll
discuss this more in the deep dive
section. Finally, the consumers will
sync one database row per subscribed
user into our incoming file chunks
table. Note that every right to this
table is item potent as we use the file
ID as our Cassandra sword key. Consumer
devices can now pull from this table on
an interval comparing the set of chunks
that they should own with the set of
cache chunks on their device. If there
are new ones that they need to fetch,
they reach out to the CDN to go get
them. The CDN itself proxies to S3. Note
that in the prior section, we need to
resolve all of the users that have
permissions for a given file when
delivering those changes to interested
users. Let's try to make this as fast as
possible. Rather than making many
different queries to our databases, we'd
prefer to use a recursive query. In
theory, this should allow us to have far
fewer network hops between our server
and database in order to resolve the set
of users with permissions for a file.
Here's an example schema and a query
that allows us to do this. If we're
planning to resolve these user
permissions at query time, we want our
queries to hit as few database shards as
possible to achieve a lower latency.
Implicitly this implies that all files
should be in the same shard as their
parent folder. Similarly, it implies
that the parent folder should be in the
same shard as its own parent folder. We
can accomplish this one fairly easily by
storing the top level folder ID in each
row. When creating a new file or folder
within an existing folder, we should
already have access to the top level
folder ID by pulling it in from the
immediate parent. This being said,
certain parent folders can have many
thousands of files inside of them and
could easily cause hotspots when
accessing their permissions. To some
extent, we could mitigate this with
adding more read replicas or a caching
layer. But at the end of the day, for
deeply nested files, these recursive
queries could get expensive. We'll
inherently have to deal with this as
long as our data is stored in a
normalized form. The fastest way to
determine the set of users with
permissions for a given file is to
simply have them all premputed. To do
this, we'd need to denormalize our data.
It would potentially be the case that if
permissions on a top level folder were
modified, we'd have to modify the set of
permissions for many thousands of files.
Keep in mind that right off the bat,
this approach raises security concerns.
If we send file changes to a user who no
longer has permissions for that file,
this could be quite bad. We discussed
how we may be able to mitigate some of
those risks in our last video with
regards to sending Facebook messages.
One way that we could premputee all
permissions for each file is with a
batch job. On some interval, we compute
the entire list of permissions for every
file and every folder. This has a couple
of downsides. For starters, in
comparison to stream processing, there's
a larger delay when permission changes
are made and when they are incorporated.
Secondly, most files are not getting
their permissions modified. So, I'll be
using a ton of extra compute to solve
this problem. Instead, we can use stream
processing to solve this problem. This
is somewhat similar to what Google
Zanzibar does with their leopard index
if you want to read more about it. The
idea here is that each file and folder
would have a mapping to the complete set
of users with permissions for it. If a
new file or new folder is created, we
first check its parent folder
permissions and inherit them. The same
applies if the entity is moved into a
different folder. If an entity has its
permissions changed, we propagate those
changes to all of its children entities.
This process goes on recursively. will
listen for change data capture on those
children and send the changes there down
to their own children. Let's diagram
this out. If we're adding permissions
for a folder that contains files, we
first put them into our permissions
table. We'll pipe a change data capture
feed into Kafka and listen to it from
our consumer. A consumer must now
compute the immediate children of the
changed entity and modify those too.
Note that when the children get
modified, these changes also get passed
back into change data capture, leading
to recursive modifications all the way
down the directory tree. For a given
entity, this means that we must be able
to quickly compute its children. We can
do so by sharding our entities table by
parent ID and then running a query to
fetch all entities with a given parent
ID. It may also help us to shard our
denormalized permissions table by parent
ID so that we only have to write changes
to one shard at a time from our Kafka
consumer. We can actually even take this
a step further and use co-artition joins
to avoid running a query on the entities
table at all. We can run change data
capture on the entities table and shard
it by parent ID. Then we can also run
change data capture on the permissions
table and shard it on the entity ID.
These can be subscribed to and joined in
Kafka streams instances. Is doing a
stream processing approach like this
worth it? Frankly, maybe not. Editing a
big parent folder could have a pretty
huge right amplification factor as we
recursively update the permissions on
all descending folders and files. Thank
you very much all for sticking around
the series. As you can see, we're just
ripping through our fan out problems.
Maybe I'll do the notification service
next week. Uh but the gist is you should
really be developing the pattern here of
how to do these fanout types of
problems. Uh a lot of them are very very
similar and as a result of that uh you
can kind of build a framework for how to
tackle these problems fairly easily.
Think about what constitutes a, you
know, popular celebrity problem fan out
type of situation. Think about how you
want to be doing all of these joins as
quickly as possible. And then in terms
of this problem, the unique parts are
going to be obviously dealing with S3,
dealing with CDNs, uh, and that kind of
interesting situation with resolving
file permissions. Hope you guys have a
great day and I'll see you in the next